bienvenue à peine émission spéciale ce
matin dans La voix est Libre nous sommes
dans un des plus beaux villages de
France sur les bords de la
rivière-lognon juste à la frontière
entre la Bourgogne et la Franche-Comté
et c'est de la fusion entre nos deux
régions que nous allons parler qu'est-ce
qui va changer pour les citoyens avec ce
rapprochement on en débat maintenant
c'est la voie est libre
dans un peu plus d'un an vous voterez
pour un nouveau conseil régional d'une
nouvelle région une grande région qui
réunira à la Bourgogne et la
Franche-Comté une fusion voulue par le
président de la République une fusion
souhaitée et engagée par les deux
présidents socialistes de Franche-Comté
de Bourgogne Marie guide du fait et
François patriac qui sont nos invités
pour une émission exceptionnelle bonjour
à tous les deux bonjour à vous Lilian
merci d'être venu de Dijon c'est un peu
plus loin de Besançon vous aviez un peu
plus de route que nous ce matin alors
madame monsieur viendront débattre avec
nous également au cours de cette
émission François Berthelon le président
du Conseil économique social et
environnemental de Bourgogne le Césaire
qui vient de rendre un avis sur le
projet de fusion difficile mais pas
impossible dit-il il nous expliquera
pourquoi et quels sont les conditions de
réussite de cette fusion selon lui et
puis également sur ce plateau dans
quelques minutes le sénateur UMP du
Doubs Jacques gros Perrin et le
municipal à Besançon une ville qui est
aujourd'hui capitale régionale et qui
craint de devenir une sous-préfecture de
Dijon on en parlera avec lui et puis
vous aussi vous pouvez participer à
cette émission devant votre télévision
votre ordinateur en commentant tout ce
qui se passe dans la voie libre avec le
mot dièse fusion BFC comme fusion
Bourgogne franchement contexte Marie
Dufay François patriars a envie de vous
poser deux questions pourquoi et
pourquoi pourquoi fusionner pourquoi
faire et d'abord pourquoi comme ça en
parlant de taille pour commencer les
deux régions Bourgogne et Franche-Comté
son petit régions à l'heure actuelle la
nouvelle région
sera la seule sous les 3 millions
d'habitants avec l'accord 13e sur 14 en
termes de PIB produit intérieur brut
finalement c'est très forme va rien
changer on était petit on va rester
petit mari guide du fait mais il faut
toujours des petits et des grands mais à
partir du moment où nous serons unis
nous serons beaucoup plus forts et nous
pourrons en faire à deux ce que nous ne
pouvons pas faire aujourd'hui séparément
et nous nous battons essentiellement
pour être d'abord aux côtés des acteurs
économiques et pour cela il faut une
force de frappe au niveau financier que
nous n'avons pas chacun du fait de notre
petite taille et de la faiblesse de nos
budgets en unissant nos budgets nous
moyens nous pourrons nous voir ouvrir
les portes de l'Union européenne par
exemple et donc ça c'est un c'est un
avantage immédiat alors qu'il y ait des
petites et des grandes régions bah oui
oui mais c'est pas le problème le
problème c'est ce qu'on va pouvoir faire
de plus pour les acteurs pour lesquels
nous travaillons parce que nous serons
Unis l'échelle de la taille elle est
pourtant importante puisqu'on dit
beaucoup que il faut de grandes régions
pour être concurrentielles avec d'autres
structures équivalentes comme
l'Allemagne par exemple François Patriat
vous êtes sénateur il y a eu un
amendement au Sénat il y a quelques
jours qui proposait plutôt de rajouter
la Bourgogne et la Franche-Comté à la
Lorraine et à Champagne-Ardenne est-ce
que ça ça ferait pas du coup une région
qui a leur elle serait extrêmement puis
tu aurais beaucoup de moyens serait-elle
gouvernable serait-elle gouvernable
est-ce que l'ensemble de ces régions
aujourd'hui
individualisés se retrouveraient dans ce
schéma ça peut se concevoir dans
d'autres territoires où on voit très
bien que une partie de la région
Limousin ou la Charente-Maritime
reconnaît des facto qu'elle appartient à
l'Aquitaine donc le problème ne se pose
pas le problème ne se pose pas pour nous
c'est différent aujourd'hui la Lorraine
la Champagne-Ardenne ne se reconnaissent
pas dans une région procimale avec la
nôtre ils ont leur
identité ils ont leur histoire ils ont
leur vécu comme nous de comme de ici
mais il n'aspire pas à cette le problème
a été posé il y avait trois scénarios
premier scénario c'est l'effacement
si on écoute les territoires certains
départements y compris en Franche-Comté
comme en Bourgogne aspire à aller dans
d'autres territoires la Saône-et-Loire à
manifesté à un moment ton attention
d'aller en Rhône-Alpes l'Yonne d'aller
en région parisienne ici le Territoire
de Belfort en Alsace l'effacement c'est
pas ce que nous avons souhaité le
deuxième scénario c'est celui de la très
grande région avec une capitale peu
identifiée et avec une gestion difficile
je crois que nous avons choisi la
troisième solution celle de la raison et
de la passion entre nous vous voyez un
petit clin d'oeil pour faire sourire au
moment où nos amis socialistes se
disputent beaucoup à Paris vous trouvez
ici deux socialistes qui s'entendent
bien c'est plutôt sympathique mais
est-ce que il le fallait-il enfin ne
fallait-il pas arrimer vous parler de
développement économique ce sera à la
compétence principale des futurs grandes
régions ne fait-il pas arrimer nos deux
petites régions à des métropoles qui
sont aujourd'hui les locomotives de
l'économie en France parce que
finalement on a l'impression que vous
avez été très volontariste tous les deux
sur cette question pour éviter justement
d'être absorbé par une plus grande
région avec un dynamisme propre non
c'est pas du tout la patineau démarche
moi le schéma métropolitain je l'ai
réfléchis aussi barigitte lui a pensé
aussi et dans le même temps nous avons
pensé que nous avons tellement de
similitudes tellement d'histoires en
commun tellement de polyconomique nous
rapproche déjà aujourd'hui une vie que
nous avons commencé ensemble avec
l'université avec nos pôles de
compétitivité avec nos réflexions sur le
financement que nous avions déjà
ensemble et puis l'idée c'est de faire
une région certes qui est grande
géographiquement mais qui va être une
région tampon entre les deux grandes
régions françaises que sont
l'Île-de-France et Rhône-Alpes une
région peut-être ou il fera où il y aura
un climat social un climat économique un
client de développement qui va se qui va
se développer mieux qu'ailleurs donc
nous avons réfléchi le schéma
métropolitain alors il faut le décliner
sur tout le territoire mais alors il
bouleverse complètement complètement le
paysage économique français ce chien là
je crois que c'est le choix à la fois de
la raison et un peu de la patient on a
parlé de compétences vous avez dit tout
à l'heure en ouverture et des choses
qu'on fera mieux pour les gens qui nous
regardent les Bourguignons les
Franc-Comtois qu'est-ce que vous ferez
mieux quand vous serez à huit
départements au lieu de 4 on
accompagnera mieux les chefs
d'entreprise on accompagnera mieux tous
les porteurs de risque qui enfin tous
ceux qui prennent des risques pour
innover et pour créer des entreprises or
c'est derrière l'emploi qui se crée de
cette façon là et le moteur de la région
aujourd'hui c'est celui-là c'est de
créer pour les habitants des emplois et
donc de créer les conditions qui
facilitent ces emplois et aujourd'hui
il faut prendre des risques aux côtés
des porteurs de projets cela nécessite
des mises de fonds des avances
remboursables des apports en fonds
propres qui nécessitent des budgets plus
importants que nous ne pouvons le faire
séparer vos deux budgets l'un
additionnés à l'autre ils vont être
divisés de la même manière je vous ai
dit que nous pourrions aussi
avoir des moyens qui viennent de que
nous ne pouvons pas avoir aujourd'hui
parce que la Banque européenne
d'investissement et bien elle a besoin
de
de budget plancher ou plafond je sais
pas comment il faut dire mais on ne peut
emprunter qu'à partir d'une d'une d'un
certain montant de budget et là nous
serons plus forts pour aller chercher
ses moyens à l'Europe et puis de toute
façon en unissant nos moyens
d'innovation à travers nos laboratoires
de recherche on sait que derrière la
recherche derrière l'innovation ce sont
les emplois de demain et bien
incontestablement nous prenons un axe là
qui est stratégique pour la création
d'emploi les autres compétences les
lycées
nous avons toujours affirmé que ce
n'était pas le premier motif le premier
motif c'est de booster l'économie et
d'être aux côtés des acteurs économiques
mais les économies elles viendront
simplement elles vont pas venir tout de
suite elle viendront tout de suite mais
pas de façon extrêmement conséquente
parce que nous allons procéder à des
achats communs des achats informatiques
des achats d'équipements nous allons
procéder à des appels d'offres communs
donc là en mutualisant nos services nous
ferons des économies mais c'est plus
tard au fur et à mesure de l'évolution
des services mais cela se fera oui mais
cela ne pourra se faire que
progressivement les personnels ils ont
un statut statut de la fonction publique
fait que demain il y a probablement des
postes qui ne seront pas remplacés quand
ils partiront en retraite au fur et à
mesure de la réorganisation mais tout
cela va se faire de façon progressive
c'est pour cela que les économies
viendront mais
progressivement
on part l'argent on peut parler
ressources peut-être aussi c'est le
moment avec quel argent avec quel argent
Marie Guy Dufay vous nous parlez des
budgets européens qui pourraient être
attribués à une région plus grande parce
que plus visible vous allez en tant que
grande région récupérer notamment une
partie des compétences des départements
est-ce que vous entendez récupérez et ce
que vous aurez les moyens de récupérer
notamment la fiscalité des départements
du fait le sujet des moyens est donc le
sujet de la fiscalité il est en débat
actuellement pour nous il y a trois
conditions à la à la réussite de cette
réforme au delà du changement de
périmètre c'est que les compétences
soient extrêmement clarifiées et que
derrière et ça c'est l'objet de la loi
qui va venir en débat et derrière les
compétences que des moyens soient
attribués le Premier ministre s'y est
engagé quand il est venu à Toulouse au
Congrès des régions de France en disant
je constate qu'effectivement face aux
responsabilités que nous attendons des
régions les moyens ne sont pas au
rendez-vous il faut travailler ses bien
et il faut vous attribuer effectivement
une fiscalité que vous n'avez pas
aujourd'hui c'est en débat et
effectivement avec le transfert de
certaines compétences des départements
on imagine qu'il peut y avoir du
transfert de fiscalité mais tout cela
est en train d'être travaillé François
Patriat sur cette question on le
rappelle aujourd'hui la marge de
manœuvre notamment fiscale des régions
est très réduite il y a pas de fiscalité
dans les régions que les choses soient
claires nous n'avons plus de fiscalité
sinon les cartes grises
90%, 8% plus de nos ressources 92 ce
sont des dotations dotation qui sont
intervenus après une réforme que j'ai
dénoncé à l'époque parce qu'elle était
d'abord inaboutie et injuste la réforme
de la taxe professionnelle qui a été la
fin de l'autonomie des régions mais donc
aujourd'hui
sans que vous en ayez les moyens un
instant avant on a tout de suite rentrer
non pas dans le détail mais dans la
technique de la fusion
on n'a pas posé la première question
faut-il réformer pourquoi réformer la
France est sclérosée et ne veut pas se
réformer pour des tas de raisons pour
des raisons des corps sociaux pour des
raisons des habitudes des gens pour pour
des raisons intellectuelles parfois
purement et moi je pense que la France a
besoin de se réformer je crois les états
majors économiques le demande l'Europe
nous le demande et il y a ceux qui ont
ce territoire voudraient encore
sanctuariser la sclérose donc nous
devons nous réformer et nous devons nous
réformer pour deux raisons première
raison nous devons être plus efficace et
mettre en commun nos moyens je vous
redonne un exemple qui n'a pas été cité
si demain par exemple on fait une
société d'économie mixte d'énergie
renouvelable demain si on l'a fait à
deux elle aura plus de moyens comme l'a
dit marigitte pour aller chercher de
l'argent à l'Europe à l'état la BU et
ailleurs on pourra demain si on fait
demain des financements pour la
recherche on l'a dit on sera plus fort
aussi pour le faire alors maintenant nos
ressources les ressources je crois que
Premier ministre a avancé au congrès de
l'ARF à Toulouse il y a 8 jours 10 jours
en disant bien entendu maintenant si des
compétences non transférées et vous avez
remarqué que les régions ne demandent
pas plus de compétences si demain on
leur donne les routes avec les trains ça
a une cohérence sur leur donne les
collèges avec les lycées et je reviens
sur le terme de proximité qui est
toujours invoqué par ceux qui sont
hostiles nous gérons aujourd'hui des
lycées qui sont à 200 km de la capitale
régionale et nous les girons en
proximité donc le problème de la
proximité est un faux problème mais
demain si nous avons des compétences
supplémentaires et j'ai dit non
cherchions pas beaucoup les régions ne
sont pas aptes demain à gérer le social
français nous faudra des ressources
transférées en dotation et une fiscalité
dynamique évolutive propre François
Patriat vous nous dites on sera plus
fort à deux mais même à deux on sera
petit il y a une concurrence aujourd'hui
entre les territoires de pauvres vont
pas faire un riche oui mais vote logique
c'est de dire il y a pas besoin de
régions quand on est la France entière
on sera encore plus riche on sera plus
grand votre raisonnement il il est un
peu par l'absurde je veux dire on a deux
régions complémentaires qui ont ensemble
du patrimoine de l'agroalimentaire de
l'Industrie de la Recherche qui veulent
aujourd'hui des universités vous avez vu
quand on veut fusionner les diversités
quand on fait la méthode volontariste ça
met 10 ans quand on veut fusionner les
régions si on y va par la loi ça met un
an donc je pense qu'il faut accélérer le
processus aujourd'hui il faut être il
pourrait processus et qu'on aura deux
régions d'ailleurs il y aura maintenant
demain non plus il y aura 15 régions et
nous ne seront pas les plus petits
la Commission a de parler
politique déjà à la fois avec le
gouvernement et entre les groupes dans
les deux assemblées l'Alsace va
reprendre son indépendance donc il y
aura à côté Lorraine et
Champagne-Ardenne et puis Languedoc
clients et Midi-Pyrénées semble que la
fusion de se fasse pas donc on en aura
15 et dans ce cadre là on sera pas les
plus petits voilà mais sur cette
question qui revient régulièrement vous
allez être les plus petits mais vous
vous posiez la question auparavant là
Franche-Comté était la plus petite et ça
vous empêchait de vivre la Bourgogne
c'est vous qui nous dites que les États
majeurs économiques étaient demandeurs
de cette fusion les chefs d'entreprise
aujourd'hui dans nos régions dites il
faut absolument confusionnent parce que
comme ça ça va créer de la croissance de
l'emploi tout ça c'est vraiment le
problème principal aujourd'hui oui mais
absolument aujourd'hui on a besoin
d'être à deux pour prendre les risques
aux côtés des porteurs de projets ça
c'est le métier de la région et donc on
sait qu'à deux en mutualisant les moyens
en unissant nos forces en allant
chercher des moyens à l'Europe on sera
plus aux côtés des acteurs de la
recherche et des acteurs économiques
mais autrement cette question qui
revient régulièrement à deux vous allez
être encore des nains mais est-ce qu'on
se posait la question là Franche-Comté
est-elle naine et telle pas naine la
Bourgogne
la comparaison
sans rentrer sans rentrer dans en
Allemagne
un million d'habitants effectivement on
a parlé des compétences quand même un
petit retour sur les compétences parce
que en même temps qu'on discute des
régions on est en train de discuter la
suppression éventuelle des conseillers
généraux on est en train de mettre en
place les métropoles moi j'avais envie
de prendre un exemple on sait que par
exemple les métropoles souhaitent avoir
la compétence économique alors on sera
peut-être pas dans ce cas là en
Bourgogne Franche-Comté parce qu'on a
pas une métropole la taille de Lyon par
exemple mais quand même est-ce que il y
a pas pour vous un vrai questionnement
aujourd'hui sur quels vont être les
compétences de ces nouveaux conseils
régionaux sachant que peut-être que les
départements vont devoir en lâcher
peut-être que les métropoles veulent en
récupérer c'est flou encore tout ça
il est admis par le Président de la
République et par le Premier ministre
que la compétence économique elle doit
aller aux régions ça repris par la loi
qui va être en débats font du lobbying
pour regarder
effectivement aujourd'hui il y a un vrai
couple institutionnel en matière de
développement économique c'est les
régions et les agglomérations donc les
régions et les métropoles et aujourd'hui
nous travaillons la main dans la main
région et agglomération donc région et
métropole c'est pareil il faut qu'on
conventionne parce que la métropole
c'est très important qu'elle est des
compétences économiques sauf que c'est
pas elle sur ce qui est en dehors du
périmètre métropolitain qui est à même
véritablement d'être responsable du
développement économique est-ce qu'on va
simplifier le millefeuille
François Patriat j'espère
quoi que ce terme soit aujourd'hui un
petit peu banalisé je crois qu'il faut
surtout clarifier il faut que les
Français que ce soit les individus les
citoyens que ce soit les porteurs de
projets que ce soit les entreprises
sachent avec qui il travaille demain et
donc en matière économique en matière
culturelle en matière touristique quel
est mon interlocuteur aujourd'hui on a
un interlocuteur multiple moi il y a
longtemps que je suis pour la
suppression de la clause générale de
compétences il faut que j'ai armée qui
permet je précise qui permet à chaque
collectivité d'intervenir sur des
projets de subventionner des projets
même en dehors de son champ de
compétence naturel tout à fait donc
c'est ça c'est d'abord une clarification
ensuite alors là je pourrais faire un
reproche à la méthode qui a été retenue
c'est que avant de dire qu'on veut
supprimer un étage il faut dire qui va
faire le job qui va faire la fonction
qui va assumer si on dit le département
de main est appelé à disparaître moi je
pense qu'il est plutôt appelé à se
transformer
dans sa nature dans ses compétences dans
sa fonction attendons la loi qui va
arriver au Sénat début de décembre on va
avoir une déclaration du Premier
ministre mardi qui va nous en parler un
peu il y aura toujours avec de grandes
régions des échelons territoriaux
intermédiaires est-ce que ce seront une
région qui sera territoriée est-ce que
ce sont un sénat des intercommunalités
la fonction sociale elle peut être
assumée dans les métropoles dans les
grandes villes bien sûr par les
agglomérations elle peut l'être en
proximité dans le territoire rural
faudra des représentants pour le faire
voilà on va continuer à essayer de
comprendre ce que signifie cette fusion
des régions avec quelqu'un qui vient de
travailler dessus la semaine dernière le
Conseil économique social et
environnemental de Bourgogne a rendu son
avis sur le projet de fusion et nous
accueillons son président François
Berthelon voilà bonjour François
Berthelin bonjour Merci vous aussi
d'être venu à peine dans ce lieu à
équidistance on va dire du cœur des
régions vous allez nous expliquer cet
avis on parlera aussi de ces fusions en
général parce que vous êtes aussi le
président le Césaire de France François
Berthelon on va redire juste en quelques
secondes pour ceux qui nous regardent ce
qu'est le Conseil économique social et
environnemental on pourrait dresser on
pourrait traiter ça en trois heures mais
en deux secondes ça fait quelques
secondes c'est la deuxième assemblée à
côté du conseil régional qui forme
l'entité régionale donc c'est un conseil
qui est composé de personnalités
issues du monde de l'entreprise donc
l'ensemble des syndicats patronaux de
salariés le monde associatif et des
personnalités qualifiées il a comme
tâche principale de répondre à toutes
les sollicitations et c'est des
compétences obligatoires des présidents
de région sur tout ce qui va être
finance et budget les contrats de plan
est en région et sur la possibilité de
s'auto saisir sur des sujets qui
impliquent la vie de la région alors la
fusion Françoise
en tout cas une base la fusion en gros
vous avez dit que vous
que ça peut se faire que ça peut marcher
mais à certaines conditions est-ce que
je le résume bien voilà en fait la
question qui nous était posée par
François Patriat et Marie guide Dufay
étaient quelles sont les conditions de
réussite pour la fusion de Bourgogne et
de Franche-Comté moi je pense à titre
personnel et on en parlera peut-être
tout à l'heure en ce qui concerne le
niveau national je pense que cette
fusion de région c'est une chose
essentielle bon c'est c'est important
pour le devenir de de du territoire
national et bien évidemment pour chacune
de nos régions parce que vous avez parlé
il y a quelques instants de la taille
des régions vous avez parlé des nains
qui font pas un grand géants etc ce
genre de discours m'agace clairement
pourquoi parce que ce n'est pas une
question de taille small is beautiful il
faut pas parler en anglais d'accord mais
c'est pas parce qu'on est petit qu'on
n'est pas bon on peut faire quelque
chose d'extrêmement performant en ayant
des petites tailles en cultivant les
synergies
c'est pas la peine de fusionner alors
mais si parce que précisément on a on a
ensemble en Bourgogne en Franche-Comté
je prendrai tout le le pôle de
compétitivité
Vitagora qu'on peut développer aussi
bien en Bourgogne qu'en Franche-Comté
mais à partir du moment où on le dit
plutôt que de simplement l'avoir un peu
dans une région et un petit peu moins
dans l'autre à partir du moment où on
annonce que toutes les entreprises
bossent ensemble ça donne du dynamisme à
tout ça le Véhicule du Futur grande
région pour que les entreprises des deux
régions travaillent ensemble écoutez les
entreprises je suis chef d'entreprise et
je le revendique fortement les
entreprises elles ont pas attendu non
plus pour bosser les unes avec les
autres que on nous annonce à une
modification administrative mais il faut
pas oublier que à partir de l'instant où
on donne des structures où on donne ce
que les deux présidents ont dit tout à
l'heure on leur donne des structures
leur permettant de travailler en commun
de se faire connaître et reconnaître pas
seulement en Bourgogne en Franche-Comté
parce qu'on se connaît un petit peu mais
vis-à-vis des cette région vis-à-vis du
National vis-à-vis de l'international là
on a véritablement de l'impact il faut
peut-être arrêter de penser que cette
réforme territoriale elle n'est faite
que pour pour nous en région non je
dirais qu'en région elle a pas d'intérêt
elle a un intérêt pour le rayonnement de
nos régions et là oui effectivement il y
a un potentiel trois conditions Adil
Césaire de Bourgogne pour sa marche si
je résume il faut que ça améliore les
conditions de vie il faut que ça permet
de garder des ressources pour mettre en
oeuvre des politiques et il faut que
cette fusion provoque un dynamisme
démocratique
alors améliorer les conditions de vie
bon on peut à peu près tous être
d'accord là-dessus gardez des ressources
pour mettre en oeuvre qu'est-ce que vous
voulez dire par là vous savez quand même
dire que il faut bien évidemment et je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
essentiel ne pas oublier que la
Bourgogne restera la Bourgogne et la
Franche-Comté restera la Franche-Comté
faire une seule unique région ne veut
pas dire fondre les deux entités l'une
de l'autre ça veut dire mettre en commun
et devenir plus efficace mais ça ne veut
pas dire demain matin que Besançon sera
l'annexe de Dijon ou Dijon l'annexe de
Besançon
ou que les francs-contois ne seront pas
lésés ou les Bourguignons c'est beaucoup
plus la mise en force des deux
territoires l'un par rapport à l'autre
on va faire réagir parce que évidemment
en Franche-Comté il y a eu ces questions
là sur l'identité fusionnées des entités
administratives ça ne veut pas dire
perdre son identité régionale évidemment
cette question d'identité elle ressort
pas simplement Franche-Comté je pense
que en Bourgogne aussi même si c'est
moins vif quand Franche-Comté alors
premièrement l'identité franc-comtoise
je ne sais pas ce que c'est il y a des
identités entre le sud du Jura et le
Nord Franche-Comté ce ne sont pas les
mêmes identités ici dans le secteur de
que je suis pas sûr qu'on se sente au
jurassien mais il y a effectivement des
identités mais qui ne sont absolument
pas solubles dans une nouvelle
organisation administrative en
Franche-Comté depuis que la
Franche-Comté existe le Jura continue
d'exister et se revendique comme tel les
Jurassiens sont toujours les Jurassiens
et pourtant la frange comtesse est
affirmée administrativement donc demain
la Grande Région Bourgogne Franche-Comté
s'affirmera administrativement avec des
des conséquences positives pour le
développement de nos territoires et donc
pour les habitants mais on aura toujours
des nivernés des côtes d'Orient des
Jurassiens il y a aucun problème par
rapport à cela François Berthelon
troisième condition je reviens à mes
trois conditions la fusion doit
provoquer un dynamisme démocratique
qu'est-ce que vous dites à François
patrial président du conseil régional de
Bourgogne pour qui un dynamisme
démocratique je vous laisse lui dire ce
que vous voulez bien
je vais oui oui
agréable contrairement à ce qu'à mon
avis vous essayez de me faire dire du
tout je pense que cette réforme comme je
l'ai dit au démarrage est une bonne
enfin c'est une réforme essentielle
cette réforme par contre elle a été
effroyablement mal préparé et engagé
elle a été elle a manqué de pédagogie
mais je dirais que c'est pas la faute
des deux des présidents de région et là
je l'ai dédouane véritablement je dis
que au niveau national cette espèce de
puzz là qu'on a voulu faire où on a
changé et on continue d'ailleurs de
changer hein il y a encore des choses
qui sont à faire c'est pas les
présidents de région qu'ils l'ont
souhaité les prisons de région ils ont
dit on souhaiterait éventuellement se
rapprocher fusionner et pourquoi pas
arriver véritablement à cette notion de
grande région mais c'est véritablement
et je cherche pas en terme politique le
Césaire ne fait pas de politique et je
me l'interdis fond de façon absolue mais
c'est au niveau national au niveau du
gouvernement à mon avis les choses ont
été mal présentées et là il y a eu un
manque de débat démocratique on n'a pas
expliqué aux gens et quand on ne connaît
pas les choses on a un certain recul
voir une certaine peur et donc nous au
Césaire par exemple on est on a fait un
débat
représentant je dirais la société civile
organisée et bien on a fait venir tout
le monde et puis les syndicats patronaux
les syndicats de salariés tout le monde
s'est exprimé en représentant tout ce
qu'il représentait là effectivement ça
commence à venir un petit peu dans les
esprits mais quand on connaît pas les
choses en général on commence par les
critiquer et c'est là où à mon avis il y
a un déficit donc je pense que il y
aurait il y aura je l'espère quelque
chose d'un peu plus exemplaire à faire
je pense à Patrier à votre réponse alors
il y a eu beaucoup de questions de poser
la méthode je vais revenir ensuite sur
la méthode le choix du gouvernement
d'abord ça fait huit ans qu'on tourne en
rond et moi je crois que nous sommes en
train de réparer le péché originel
lorsque ont été créés les régions dans
les années 70 on a déjà fait des grandes
régions et des petites régions parce
qu'on a pensé que calquer uniquement sur
l'histoire sans penser à l'économie ça
pouvait marcher je prends l'exemple
d'une région qui ne change pas
aujourd'hui on va prendre Provence
alcote d'Azur est-ce que vous pensez
aujourd'hui que les métropoles de
Marseille ou de Nice ont un rôle néfaste
sur l'ensemble du territoire est-ce que
ces départements aussi métropoles
n'aident pas par ailleurs le territoire
que sont les abdos de Provence ce qui a
digne on n'est pas content d'avoir une
région qui soit aujourd'hui donc la
question ne se pose pas pour eux ils
appartiennent à la région PACA ils ont
été englobés au départ et si on avait
fait la région Bourgogne Franche-Comté
on sera pas là aujourd'hui bien on
essaye d'avancer
en second lieu
est-ce que
élan démocratique derrière et il m'a
écouté j'étais hier à la maison
familiale d'agent cours canton de
Nuits-Saint-Georges très belle ville
mondialement connue même sur la lune et
écoutez j'avais à côté de moi j'avais à
côté de moi le président des maisons
familiales de Bourgogne m'a dit mais
vous allez tout à fait raison monsieur
Patriat voilà une balle la base comment
ça va se décliner il a dit nous devons
faire tout de suite l'association des
Maisons Familiales Rurales Bourgogne
Franche-Comté et je pars y travaillait
cet après-midi vous voyez
c'est les gens qui ont des rapports avec
le Césaire par exemple mais le citoyen
de la rue le bourguignon de la rue le
Franc-Comtois de la rue dans un an on
est en campagne électorale probablement
pour les nouvelles régions le
bourguignon de la rue il connaît pas ses
maisons familiales et il pense pas que
demain il y aura un meilleur tissu un
meilleur réseau qui l'a compris pourquoi
on va pourquoi les deux régions vont
fusionner le Bourguignon
mais est-ce que on tourne autour de la
question par exemple du référendum de
demander leur avis aux gens là-dessus il
y a déjà eu un sondage François
général de Côte-d'Or que vous connaissez
bien qui est député par ailleurs dites
depuis le début ils font un référendum
absolument il veut il fait un référendum
il veut un référence mais j'ai compris
mais j'ai compris que Françoise
j'ai déjà compris que François Sauvade a
déjà intégré lui-même personnellement
politiquement la fusion Bourgogne
Franche-Comté qu'il y pense d'ailleurs
très fort je lui reproche pas d'ailleurs
il a raison déclaré il peut dire il
critique il critique sans doute la
méthode c'est le rôle de l'opposant
c'est le rôle de l'opposant cette
méthode a été la meilleure non mais
quand je vous dis que depuis six ans on
tourne en rond et quand enfin le
gouvernement maintenant dit aux élus ben
écoutez vous avez assez joué vous avez
ces jouets je décide et j'avance et bien
je soutiens le gouvernement quand il le
fait j'aimerais revenir à la question du
dynamisme démocratique je vais vous
redonner la parole François Berthelon
reste que notamment dans les campagnes
en Franche-Comté ou en Bourgogne dans
les petits villages il y a aujourd'hui
un sentiment d'abandon par les pouvoirs
publics et des villages qui ont perdu
leur poste il y a des sous-préfectures
qui n'ouvrent plus aux horaires qui
qu'elles ouvraient auparavant c'est ce
qu'on appelle la France périphérique et
un sentiment d'abandon d'éloignement des
centres de décision et reste que ce
projet de fusion il s'inscrit dans cette
élan là comment répondre que répondre à
ces citoyens qui se sentent aujourd'hui
abandonnés
alors vous allez me parler des bureaux
de poste service public d'accord maman
quand je vais dans un conseil municipal
on me dit ma poste à fermer et que
j'interroge les conseillers municipaux
ils sont 11 ou 15 et genre des combien
parmi vous un compte à la poste et qui
ne l'ont pas parce que c'est pas eux qui
ont abandonner le service public est-ce
que c'est pas eux comme on est le
service public donc
à ses citoyens qui s'interrogent sur
l'éloignement des services publics des
centres de décision
la région est plus grande ça va
accentuer ce sentiment
vous êtes en train de flatter les
mauvais penchants et moi j'apprécie pas
ça non non est-ce que vous avez pensé
qu'on a changé est-ce que vous avez
pensé qu'on est à l'heure du numérique
et qu'aujourd'hui interroger les
agriculteurs il se posent pas le
problème de la peur de la proximité ils
font tous les jours leur déclaration
pack en ligne il faut pas ils ont pas
besoin d'avoir la DDA je reviens à
l'exemple de Lyon en quelques années
cette sous-préfecture d'hôtes Saône a
perdu sa maternité Lure lui en
Haute-Saône ça maternité Marie du fait
pour confirmer le commissariat le la
prison très récemment voilà ce sont des
services publics qui partent dans une
ville moyenne et aujourd'hui les
habitants de ces territoires là se
sentent abandonnés par les prisons parce
qu'il y a peu la présence
publique ce sont des services
effectivement de l'État la Région n'a
absolument rien à voir que le sentiment
général est le même par rapport à ce
sentiment général moi je pense que la
fusion
change rien que aujourd'hui la région
qu'elle soit fusionnée ou pas fusionné
elle doit effectivement répondre à cette
question non pas des services publics
qui sont délaissés parce que la
population diminue mais de dans tous les
territoires il y a de l'initiative et
comment est-ce qu'on porte cette
initiative comment on l'a transforme en
entreprise parce que aujourd'hui nous
avons besoin de créer des emplois et le
métier de la région il est d'accompagner
la prise d'initiative économique donc
moi je réponds à cela non pas par
rapport au service public qui dépend de
l'état je réponds par rapport à la
compétence de la région qui est de
booster le développement économique nous
devons être très proche des territoires
et la région elle doit pas attendre
qu'on vienne la voir en lui disant bah
tiens on a tel projet est-ce que vous
êtes prêt à nous subventionner elle doit
être tête chercheuse dans tous les
territoires et se doter des moyens pour
être peut-être chercheuse dans tous les
territoires de l'initiative François
Berthelin je vous propose de prendre un
petit peu de hauteur on était allure moi
je voulais je voulais monter je voulais
rebondir pour la question des maternité
je voulais je voulais parler je voulais
parler de votre deuxième casquette c'est
président des Césaire de France parce
que là on parle de Bourgogne
Franche-Comté on a remarqué que là où il
y a eu un certain nombre de
manifestations publiques autour de ces
fusions je pense à l'Alsace-Lorraine par
exemple mais il y a eu la Bretagne aussi
il y a eu un certain nombre on va dire
de relents pas toujours très glorieux
sur l'image que les uns et les autres
ont des régions qui vont être amenés à
fusionner on va dire
est-ce que la Bourgogne Franche-Comté
est très avancée et est-ce que vous de
votre point de vue quand vous parlez
avec tous les autres Césaire de France
il y a des inquiétudes plus marquées il
y a des impossibilités beaucoup plus
fortes
à mettre en place ces fusions alors vous
m'excuserez mais je vais reprendre la
parole sur la fin de la dernière
question
on va repasser au National aussi tout de
suite derrière je pense que dans tout ce
qu'on est en train de se dire il y a un
tout petit peu de surréalisme parce que
quand on se dit effectivement il y a
s'éloigne les territoires il y a des
manques etc mais il va quand même
falloir aussi un jour intégrer le fait
qu'on a plus de sous et que donc
malheureusement et bien l'état manque de
de de ressources aujourd'hui les régions
mangent de ressources et la question des
transferts et des financements des
régions me semblent à un point
absolument capital c'est pas par plaisir
qu'on ferme effectivement des des points
qui sont essentiels mais c'est aussi
parce que au niveau national et donc
obligatoirement mon niveau régional il y
a quand même vraiment des soucis majeurs
arrêtons de nous cacher derrière le
petit doigt faut quand même le dire bon
voilà ça c'était mon petit coup de
gueule très rapide mais je reviens au
National au national alors effectivement
Bourgogne et Franche-Comté je dirais que
le mot Bourgogne Franche-Comté c'est un
mot qui coule tout seul ça fait
longtemps qu'on en parle ça ça marche
bien et nos deux présidents de région
ont été les deux premiers d'ailleurs ils
nous ont mis un chantier assez
extraordinaire au démarrage parce que
ils nous ont un peu tous surpris parce
j'attendais pas cette annonce ils vous
ont dit ils vous ont brusquez un peu on
a été un petit peu brusqué mais de temps
en temps ça fait pas de mal et donc on
s'est tous mis à bosser les présidents
de région dans les trois jours qui ont
suivi ce sont mis à travailler ensemble
et donc on se rend compte d'une chose
c'est que il y a un certain nombre de
régions qui se mettent à fonctionner il
y a des régions dans lesquelles c'est
catastrophique ou je dirais que c'est
presque les conseillers économiques qui
font le lien entre les deux Conseils
régionaux qui se parlent le plus je
prends le cas de Midi-Pyrénées et de
Languedoc-Roussillon par exemple bon il
y a la question de l'Alsace qui est
difficile et c'est vrai que il y a des
régions où les choses se passent mal je
me permets de dire au moins pour une
fois soyons heureux soyons fiers en
chantant Bourgogne je suis fier d'être
Bourguignons et on laissera fier d'être
Bourgogne franche-comtois et bien je
pense que Bourgogne et Franche-Comté
sont presque un modèle dans le genre
parce que je trouve que les choses se
passent quand même même s'il y a de sa
coince un peu ça se passe quand même
vraiment pas mal et justement avant que
le mariage se fasse est-ce que vous avez
recensé déjà tous les points sur
lesquels on est déjà marié en réalité
entre Bourgogne et Franche-Comté est-ce
que le César les Césaire l'ont fait
François Berthelin les césaires ont
travaillé dessus puisque ça fait partie
du rapport qu'on a rendu il y a une
semaine qui est d'ailleurs consultable
sur le site du Césaire donc mais je veux
pas faire quelque chose de trop long en
la matière mais il est vrai qu'en
matière d'éducation d'université de
santé il y a déjà énormément de choses
qui ont été faites et donc il y a des
choses qui fonctionnent déjà je ne vais
pas parler des entités bancaires qu'ils
l'ont fait ou économiques qui l'ont fait
depuis longtemps en termes on parlait
tout à l'heure des entreprises des
entreprises non pas non pas de
frontières entre la Bourgogne et la
Franche-Comté je le dis encore c'est une
la fusion des deux régions qui est une
synergie qui doit se mettre en place
pour leur donner plus d'impact mais ça
marche déjà il y a déjà beaucoup de
choses qui fonctionnent bien on va vous
remercier
François Berthelon pour votre avis
éclairé sur cette sur cette question va
accueillir un nouvel invité sur ce
plateau un élu UMP Jacques Grosperrin
conseiller municipal d'opposition à son
capital régional de la Franche-Comté
Jacques gros père inquiétait conseillé
régional également jusqu'à il y a
quelques semaines jusqu'à son élection
au Sénat les désormais sénateur UMP et a
donc participé au débat qui a commencé
cette semaine sur la réforme
territoriale bonjour Jacques d'opéra
vous souhaitiez interpeller nos deux
présidents de région notamment sur la
place de Besançon dans cette future
organisation territoriale je vous laisse
la parole bonjour pas simplement
interpellé simplement leur dire et je
reconnais c'est vrai la pugnacité de de
Mary guide et de François Patriat
vis-à-vis de cette réforme que le colon
ressent c'est simplement plutôt
m'étonner de la manière dont elle a été
engagée parce que le Président de la
République lorsqu'il était candidat
c'était son engagement 54 disait je
demanderai une participation plus forte
des élus une intervention plus plus
prégnante vis-à-vis de cette nouvelle
étape des décentralisation et je me
rends compte ça a été fort bien dit tout
à l'heure que c'est une réforme qui est
nécessaire d'ailleurs les Français
l'attendent les Français ne veulent plus
de ces empilement des si différents
types d'échelons qui existent à ce jour
simplement elle a été précipitée elle
était bâclée elle était mal contournée
en gros ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que il aurait été plus intéressant de
prendre le pouls des Français de
discuter en amont et non pas de faire ce
qu'on appelle cet exercice de rattrapage
que l'on retrouve à ce jour puisse
essayer de justifier une décision qui a
été prise au début juin avec le
président de la République et l'ensemble
des barons du PS d'essayer de faire ces
régions qui correspondaient plus à des
engagements politiques à des engagements
philosophiques culturels
sur le fond de la réforme mais pas sur
la forme on est d'accord pour le fait
qu'il y a à ce jour trop d'échelons en
France il faut simplifier des choses
simplement cette réforme actuellement ne
simplifie pas et ne supprime aucun
échelon on le voit bien les doublons
existeraient il aurait été intéressant
de réfléchir également sur le le sur
l'état je crois qu'il faut réformer
l'État qu'est-ce qui va arriver au
niveau des sous-préfectures qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire du direct qu'est-ce qu'on
va faire des fonds régionaux d'art
contemporains qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
de tout un ensemble de de de doublons
pas de doublons mais qui existe à ce
jour il y a deux académies il y a
l'Académie de Besançon il y a l'Académie
de Dijon est-ce qu'on va fusionner
est-ce qu'on va enchaîner un ensemble de
choses vis-à-vis de cela je crois que la
réforme de l'État est une réforme
nécessaire la forme je l'ai dit le fond
on l'a bien vu il aurait été plus
intéressant déjà de donner les contours
les compétences qui va faire quoi à ce
jour on ne sait pas qui va faire quoi ça
change tous les jours le calendrier
change les choses changent c'est une
réforme à préparer non fonctionnel et
nous sommes inquiets nous les élus
bizontales et Francis
Dufay beaucoup de questions de Jacques
Grosperrin que pouvez-vous lui répondre
sur la méthode je sais pas s'il y a une
méthode parfaite et puis j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire qu'effectivement
elle est pas complètement parfaite la
méthode mais on a le mérite d'avoir acté
un chemin vers la réforme jusqu'à
maintenant on parlait il y avait des
rapports il y avait des commissions sur
la réforme territoriale mais on passait
pas à l'acte là on est passé à l'acte de
façon effectivement
assez désordonné c'est vrai sur la
réforme de l'État mais alors je suis à
100% d'accord quand on parle des
doublesnements il y a bien plus de
doublement entre les compétences d'une
région et celle de l'État contre région
et départements il y a effectivement une
sorte d'unanimité politique pour dire
qu'il faut aussi que cette réforme des
régions s'accompagne d'une réforme de
l'État mais l'état pourquoi engager
le travail est en train d'être fait
aujourd'hui dans l'ombre il nous est
annoncé une
revue des missions de l'État en région
avec des premiers résultats pour janvier
ou février le Premier ministre l'a
annoncé le travail est en train d'être
fait et je sais qu'en tout cas sur nos
deux régions Bourgogne et Franche-Comté
les deux préfets de région sont en train
de travailler ensemble à rechercher la
façon la meilleure
d'équilibrer les services entre ceux de
l'État et ceux des régions François
Patriat vous voyez hocher la tête quand
Jacques gros Perrin juste à côté de vous
disait justement il faut réformer l'État
vous êtes d'accord je vais venir mais
vous savez les réformes de structure les
Francs couteau et les Bourguignons qui
nous regardent je suis pas sûr que ça
les passionne vraiment
ce qui les passionne c'est votre
question
et on est passé trop vite dessus ce
sentiment d'abandon qui est réel qui est
réel bien et que les Bourguignons et les
francs-contois ressentent il faut pas le
flatter il faut essayer au contraire
dire remédier ensemble et quand on dit
tout le monde applaudit
des remèdes ils sont inquiets ils sont
inquiets si on supprime
de leurs sentiments d'être éloignés des
services comme vous l'avez dit moi je
renverse la question je dis est-ce qu'il
ne faut pas dans chaque partie du
territoire je suis rural j'habite rural
je virale je veux des campagnes vivantes
dans des espaces de qualité et de
proximité et la proximité elle
s'organise de façon intelligente
aujourd'hui quand vous ne parlez d'une
maternité qui ferme j'entends bien le
désespoir le territoire la maternité une
maternité un tribunal un commissariat de
police
commissariat de police quand on a
réformé les gendarmerie je
dans le sens de l'abandon contraire mais
essayons d'y apporter des remèdes
intelligents alors pour répondre à la
question qui m'a été posée ensuite alors
là je considère que la réforme de l'État
elle est nécessaire et adjacente à la
réforme territoriale on va poser le
problème des sous-préfectures regardez
sur un territoire que je connais bien
Bourgogne Franche-Comté sous préfecture
Avallon sans tonnerre sous-préfecture à
Louhans à Charolles à Autun à Chalon
alors si je dis ça aujourd'hui on va
dire ça y est patria et contre les
préfecture non mais est-ce que
maintenant elle va sauter il faut
repenser je pense par exemple quand dort
une sous-préfecture à Montbard c'est
bien sous-préfecture à Dijon c'est bien
faut-il le sous-préfecture à Beaune je
vais me faire beaucoup d'ennemis ce
matin mais je pense que il faut y
réfléchir ensemble parce que est-ce que
maintenant avec le mode de déplacement
avec la façon dont une il utilise la
préfecture ou la sous-préfecture on peut
réfléchir autrement et il va il en va de
même de des services publics si demain
il y a des doublons entre les régions et
l'État et ben ce processus il est engagé
inexorablement les services d'ailleurs
le son bien et il faudra le faire à tout
prix monsieur gros-père en question d'un
journaliste bourguignon un élu
franc-comtois est-ce que derrière ce que
vous dites il y a de façon sous-tendue
la peur pour les élus Byzantins par
exemple de se trouver noyer dans quelque
chose ou de perdre dans cette fusion
nous nous sommes les réformateurs et
vous vous êtes les conservateurs alors
que ce n'est pas ça nous sommes pour une
réforme mais nous ne sommes pas pour ce
type de réformes là la dette de la
Bourgogne est de 360 euros par an par
habitant par habitant la dette de la
Franche-Comté de l'ordre de 170 euros
donc la dette de la bourgeoise pour la
Bourgogne 264 € pour la France
tout à fait donc deux fois plus
importantes qu'est-ce qu'on va faire une
fois que les budgets seront fusionnés
est-ce que cette dette bourguignonne
sera prise en charge par les Bisontins
tout en sachant qu'actuellement
l'équilibre du territoire a déjà été
fait les grands travaux étaient faits
les grandes perspectives ont été faites
etc il va falloir un moment donné se
dire que la dette bourguignonne ce sont
les Franc-Comtois qui vont la payer
alors justement
vous avez fait le plaisir de venir
discuter de cette question là avant
l'été même et vous m'aviez dit à
l'époque oui mais ça c'est un atout pour
la Franche-Comté pour négocier avec la
Bourgogne alors que peut-on négocier
quand on a une dette deux fois moindre
que le petit général avec lequel on le
s’associe faut arrêter avec cette
histoire de dette qui affichée comme un
chiffon rouge parce que aujourd'hui ceux
qui sont contre la réforme avance ce
chiffon rouge la dette la dette alors
d'abord la dette c'est pas sale la dette
c'est la dette des collectivités elle
est faite pour investir aujourd'hui on
parle de la dette de la France et on est
très inquiet de la dette de la France et
la dette de la France elle a rien à voir
avec la dette des collectivités les
collectivités n'ont pas le droit de
s'endetter pour leur dépense courante de
fonctionnement les collectivités
empreintes et donc augmentent leur dette
pour investir investir dans les TER
investir dans les lycées avec investir
dans les grandes infrastructures et la
Bourgogne a énormément investi au niveau
des trains tout à l'heure le président
Patriat l'a dit effectivement il y a un
réseau ferré qui est beaucoup plus dense
que celui de la Franche-Comté et donc je
pense qu'une partie de la dette de la
Bourgogne elle vient de cela elle de la
Bourgogne elle est en train parce que
une dette ça s'analise pas à l'instant t
on regarde ça sur les années à venir la
dette de la Bourgogne elle est en train
de décroître au moment où la dette des
franc-comtois du fait de nos
acquisitions de ter du fait de notre
plan lycée d'investissement est en train
de monter donc c'est un vrai faux sujet
alors
excusez-moi c'est un atout pour la
Franche-Comté au moment de négocier avec
la Bourgogne
qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière cette
négociation mais la négociation ça va
être le travail de fusion de nos budgets
et nous allons voir effectivement nos
engagements ce que nous appelons nos
engagements de programme à nous
autorisations
on va voir qu'effectivement aujourd'hui
pour les 5 ou 6 années qui viennent les
autorisations de programme de la France
comtesse sont probablement plus
importantes que celle de la Bourgogne
parce que on a un retard en matière de
de d'investissement François Patriot
vous vouliez répondre à mon collègue
sénateur que j'écoute avec attention sur
la méthode et la réforme vous savez ça
c'est aussi un mal français tout le
monde pense qu'il faut une grande
réforme fiscale tout le monde pense
qu'il faut une grande réforme
territoriale tout le monde pense qu'il
faut des réformes simplicitées tout le
monde veut des réformes si jamais la
bonne c'est toujours pour les autres
toujours pour les autres l'Europe
pourrait former l'Europe mais c'est une
autre Europe qu'on veut c'est toujours
jamais celle propose on en propose une
aujourd'hui qui est malgré tout
l'aboutissement de travaux
parlementaires et gouvernementaux depuis
six ans il y a eu la commission crating
gebelo il y a eu la commission Raffarin
il y a eu le rapport fait par l'ancien
Premier ministre j'ai participé à toutes
ces commissions et on avait débouché sur
une forme de consensus qui n'a pas
abouti le jour où on a inventé le
conseiller territorial après on a tout
remis sur le chantier aujourd'hui c'est
une elle est sans doute pas parfaite je
suis d'accord avec vous on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui supprimer un échelon sans
avoir dit avant qu'il va le faire mais
au moins elle a le mérite d'avancer et
l'Europe la regarde d'un bon œil et ça
va nous arranger peut-être dans les
discussions de budgétaire aujourd'hui
François patron la dette je peux
répondre sur la vie alors d'abord je
voudrais pas laisser croire que la
Bourgogne est endettée au-delà du
possible la Bourgogne elle est dans la
moyenne des régions nous sommes en 13e
14e position sur 22 aujourd'hui mais je
rappelle quand même aux francs-contois
que l'aigle vers un Rhône nous en avons
10 km en Bourgogne et qu'on en a payé
près de 100 millions
ça pèse dans le 300 millions d'emprunt
aujourd'hui et je m'en félicite et je
veux que nous la terminions ensemble je
veux que demain je veux que nous la
tourminions ensemble nous terminions
personne ne parle de la dette de
l'Alsace aujourd'hui elle est trois fois
supérieure à la nôtre pourquoi ils ont
payé de LGV parce qu'ils ont investi
aujourd'hui ce que nous avons investir
ce que nous avons investi aujourd'hui
parce que nous avons emprunté pour
investir à l'université dans la culture
dans l'économie ça servira aussi demain
aux francs-contois comme les
investissements francontois serviront
demain au bourguignon alors on va
discuter entre nous nous rapprochons nos
budget aujourd'hui nous rapprochons nos
radios financiers on arrivera à quelque
chose d'intelligent pour le
développement harmonieux de territoires
François Berthelin vous êtes resté avec
nous alors moi j'en profite pour vous
faire rebondir sur ce que disait
monsieur gros Perrin sur la peur des
Byzantins de devenir une sous-préfecture
de Dijon et dans vos travaux ça existe
bien sûr ça c'est inquiétude
et c'est quoi comparer des villes
finalement je vais vous dire très
sincèrement on a travaillé de façon
assez exemplaire entre les deux conseils
économiques on a beaucoup travaillé
ensemble et au début on a vraiment
ressenti je vous le dis je parle très
sincèrement on a vraiment ressenti une
crainte des franc-comtois et des
Bisontins par rapport au dijonnais et au
Bourguignons c'est vrai et ça c'est
absolument vrai je pense que on a mérite
énorme déjà dans nos deux assemblées
c'est qu'on a commencé à travailler
ensemble et à se comprendre et à mieux
s'apprécier et à on est en train de
démonter un petit peu cette peur je
reviens à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure manque de pédagogie au démarrage
égal cette crainte cette peur qui a
existé moi je peux vous le dire parce
que je suis je suis né à Dijon je suis
farouchement attaché à mon territoire
absolument mais vraiment c'est un
territoire que j'aime et je peux vous
dire une chose quand j'entends dire les
Bourguignons vont bouffer la
Franche-Comté ou Dijon mais c'est pour
moi ça me paraît aberrant j'entends et
je l'ai entendu fortement de la part de
nos collègues Byzantins me dire Dijon va
bouffer Besançon et bien moi je peux
vous dire une chose en tant que jeune et
en tant que bourguignon mais en tant que
dijonnais pour répondre précisément à
question je ne reçois absolument pas ça
de la part des Dijonnais par rapport au
franc-comtois et au byzantin vraiment ce
n'est pas la culture des Bourguignons de
d'aller dans ce sens-là et je peux vous
dire une chose c'est en travaillant
ensemble c'est en continuant de faire ce
qu'on a commencé qu'on va arriver à
démonter cette peur François Berthelon
rapport de vos collègues francontois le
Conseil économique social et
environnemental franc-comtois dit je
cite qu'il faut mettre en oeuvre un
leadership basé sur un pacte d'équilibre
et de coopération entre les deux
capitales régionales
Marie Dufay impact d'équilibre c'est
quoi et très concrètement où sera
l’hôtel de région
je sais pas si c'est ce qui était
terminé à l'Hôtel de Région
la politique est faite de symboles
souvent il faut il faudra pas les
négliger bien sûr vous voulez une
réponse à celle-là je peux dire que
l'Hôtel de Région pourra être à Besançon
et la préfecture à Dijon par exemple ou
vice-versa mais moi ce que je voulais
vous dire c'est surtout que on est en
train d'entrer dans une réforme on est
en train d'inventer autre chose pour le
développement de nos territoires nous
n'avons pas de métropole Dijon n'est pas
une métropole Besançon n'en n'est pas
une et il nous faut dans ce grand
territoire d'équilibre que nous allons
développer entre d'un côté Paris
Strasbourg et Lyon il nous faut
développer quelque chose d'autre et il
nous faudra je pense dans l'avenir
arrêtez de parler de la capitale
régionale parce que nous aurons à
construire un équilibre
qui sera un axe métropolitain entre
Dijon et Besançon et cela passe par un
projet politique parce que jusqu'à
maintenant effectivement il n'y avait
aucune régulation aucun projet politique
Besançon et Dijon ou guerre coopérer
mais les deux régions tout en ayant
quelques coopérations se tourner plutôt
le dos aujourd'hui nous sommes
fondamentalement dans autre chose et
nous aurons besoin nous aurons besoin
effectivement de faire en sorte qu'il y
ait une harmonie de développement et
puisque la question des services de
l'État et des services des régions va se
poser mais il va falloir voir quelle
répartition harmonieuse on fait
imaginons que
Dijon qui est un grand axe ferroviaire
garde les services transport de la
région et que Besançon garde les
services éducatifs par exemple merci
merci beaucoup Marie guide dufebvre
François Berthelon vous aviez envie
encore de continuer mais il nous reste
15 secondes avant le journal de midi
donc je suis obligé de vous remercier
d'être venu à peine monsieur Berthelon
monsieur Grosperrin Marie Guy Dufay
François Patriat vous restez avec nous
pour la deuxième partie de la voie libre
ce sera juste après les informations de
midi qui vont commencer dans une poignée
de minutes on va parler un petit peu de
scénario politique peut-être aussi pour
pour la région à tout de suite